also es waren noch zu viele lehrer mit
schnupfen da ist bleiben einfach zu
viele zu hause ist gewöhnen sich ohnehin
im augenblick relativ viele menschen
daran
ein leben ohne arbeit zu führen das ist
in der krise richtig nur ich habe diese
woche in einem hotel übernachtet wo
praktisch überhaupt kein personal mehr
vorhanden war
also wir müssen ein bisschen aufpassen
dass wir uns nicht alle daran gewöhnen
dass wir ohne arbeit leben können wir
müssen zurück an die arbeit ich mache
kein geheimnis daraus dass ich skeptisch
bin ob diese sehr lange verlängerung des
kurzarbeitergelds bis ende 20 21 die
richtige lösung ist das ist jetzt
entschieden aber den arbeitsmarkt
beobachten müssen
meine befürchtung ist wir bekommen die
mitarbeiter dort wo sie weil sie
brauchen wo wir sie dringend brauchen
nicht weil sie fest gebunden sind an die
firmen von denen die kurzarbeitergeld
oder für die sie kurzarbeitergeld
bekommen schauen was uns an im laufe der
nächsten wochen und monate die lage
verhält hat schön noch zur wahl das
kurzarbeitergeld
ja ich habe mir auch so zwischendurch
mal die frage gestellt hätte die
koalition das eigentlich auch gemacht
wenn wir im herbst 2021 keine
bundestagswahl gehabt hätte und wie war
die tiefe wahrscheinlich hätte man das
quartalsweise nach vorne geschrieben und
nicht jetzt mal hat es nicht es ist eine
spekulation